[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROGER MARTINEZ: A secure
Google Cloud project
is a happy Google Cloud
project, and a big part
of maintaining that security is
securing your service accounts.
Remember, access
to resources can
be granted to service
accounts in the same way
that they can be
granted to users.
And not only are they designed
to be used by applications
and virtual machines, they can
be accessed by other users,
too.
That means that
a service account
that's set up with access
to too many resources
and that's accessible
by too many users
introduces a serious
vulnerability.
So in this episode,
we'll talk about what's
what with securing your
service account's roles
and permissions.
When thinking about securely
managing service accounts,
you could start by
asking two questions--
what resources can
your service accounts
access, and what permissions
do your service accounts need?
For example, let's take
this service account
with the editor role assigned.
What resources can this
service account access?
Well, with the editor
role, the answer
is pretty much all of them.
OK, so what permissions does
this service account need?
The answer to that
will depend on what
you need the service
account to do,
and it's likely to be a lot less
than the permissions associated
with the editor role.
This means that you'll have to
adjust the project's IAM policy
to delegate the appropriate
IAM roles and permissions.
When you do that, it's best
to adhere to the principle
of least privilege.
That means assigning
to your service account
the minimum access required for
it to carry out its intended
function.
Any account with permissions
beyond what it needs
introduces an unwanted
security risk.
So steer clear of assigning
broad roles to your service
accounts, like owner
or editor, especially
in a production environment.
This is true even for
default service accounts that
are created for you with the
editor role assigned right
off the bat.
Yeah, it's useful
for development.
But make sure to narrow things
down when turning things up
for production.
Applying the principle
of least privilege
also means limiting
which users have access
to your service accounts.
Access to your service accounts
can mean different things
since there are a number
of predefined IAM roles
that will grant users
permissions over your service
accounts in different ways.
Let's talk about
some of these service
account-related roles that might
impact your project security.
First up, we have the Create
Service Account and Delete
Service Account roles.
They allow users to do
exactly what their names say--
create new service accounts
and delete existing service
accounts, respectively.
It's worth noting that
the Create role on its own
doesn't let you do anything
beyond creating a new service
account.
You'll need to be granted
additional permissions
to make changes to its roles
or to manage its IAM policy.
Likewise, the
Delete role does not
include the permissions to
undelete, disable, or enable,
only delete service accounts.
Up next is that Service
Account User role.
With this role,
users are allowed
to act as a service account
to run certain operations.
For example, a user
that has the permission
to create Compute Instances,
Cloud Functions, or AppEngine
Apps will need the
service account user
role assigned so that they can
attach a service account to any
of those resources.
Next there's Service
Account Admin.
A user with this role can do all
administrative tasks on service
accounts-- enable them,
disable them, delete them,
and update their details.
They can even make changes
to the service account IAM
policies so a user of this role
can delegate access to service
accounts to other users.
For that reason, the
Service Account Admin role
is very powerful and should
be delegated very carefully,
if at all.
Another administrative
role for service accounts
is a Service Account
Key Admin role.
Users of this role will be
able to create and delete
service account private keys.
These keys can be
used by other users
to run commands as a
corresponding service account.
As you can probably guess,
this can become problematic,
especially if you have a
boatload of keys floating
around without an effective way
of tracking them or managing
their distribution.
This is another role
that you'll want
to delegate very carefully.
And finally, there is a
Service Account Token Creator.
With this role, a
user is able to use
the impersonate-service-account
flag to run gcloud commands
as a specified service account.
Now, this kind of
impersonation doesn't
require the use of
any private keys
and is considered a
safer alternative.
The Service Account
Token Creator role
also lets users create
OAuth2 access tokens,
sign blobs, or generate
self-signed JSON Web Tokens.
The Service Account User, Admin,
Key Admin, and Token Creator
roles I mention could be
granted to any account
by adding the binding to
a project's IAM policy.
But watch out.
By granting them on
a project's policy,
it will grant those permissions
on every service account
that exists on that project.
Now, this likely goes
against the principle
of least privilege and is
generally not a great idea.
Instead, you can avoid
overdelegating access
to service accounts by editing
individual service account IAM
policies.
Service accounts
aren't just accounts.
They're also
considered resources
with an attached IAM policy.
By binding users to these roles
on individual service accounts,
you will decrease the
likelihood that a user will
make an accidental change
and substantially decrease
the blast radius if a user
account is ever compromised.
Do your best to grant users
access only to the service
accounts that they
actually need.
It's also worth noting
that yes, service accounts
can be granted these roles
on other service accounts.
So take into account
instances where
a user can have indirect
access to a service account
through another service account.
You can see a service
account's IAM policy
with gcloud iam service-accounts
get-iam-policy followed
by a service account.
By understanding
the roles associated
with service
accounts and by doing
a thorough review
of your IAM policies
to apply the principle
of least privilege,
you'll be taking major
steps towards maintaining
a safe and secure project.
But that's not all.
Even after you've done
that, there's still more
you need to know about
securing your service accounts.
Next time, we'll spend
some time talking
about securely impersonating
service accounts
and effectively managing
their private keys.
See you there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]